ready now here's a little story that I
got to tell about three bad brothers
that you know so well it started way
back in history with that Rocco CA and
me dude
what we're gonna do right here is go
back way back back to the time
in the early 80s everyone in our scene
was in the bed we wanted to be rappers
so bad but we were mediocre at best most
rappers hold their rhymes and little
pieces of paper right
we weren't from being famous in a 14
block radius to being on tour with
Madonna and Rick Rubin the show's kept
getting bigger and bigger we morphed
from making fun a party Bros to actually
becoming those dudes we were burning out
I just didn't even recognize a person
that I had become at that point you know
hold out it's not over yet go there's
not that many times in your life when
you realize you're in a new chapter we
changed how we wanted to be as people
and friends we got inspired and while
experimenting we found our voice it's
coming back Adam is coming back
[Music]
Adam Yauch was the driving force the one
that not only gets themselves going and
doing great things
but says we should all do this Yoko's
that type friend
young Mike and I have spent more time
with each other than with our own
families it's not like all of it was
easy or highlight filled but who gets to
work every day with their two best
friends
you
you